[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Katja streso für
den Sport einen schönen guten Abend
schauen wir auf die Themen von heute
mehr Munition für die Ukraine auf der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz bestätigt
die EU-Pläne für gebündelte Großaufträge
an die Rüstungsindustrie
mehr Unterstützung für Erdbebenopfer die
Bundesregierung will die humanitäre
Hilfe um weitere 22 Millionen Euro
aufstocken
und der Schwarm feiert Premiere die
Berlinale präsentiert die Verfilmung des
Bestsellers von Frank Schätzing als ZDF
Mehrteiler
[Musik]
wir haben mehr Durchhaltevermögen als
Vladimir Putin das sagte der Chef der
Sicherheitskonferenz Heusgen heute zum
Abschluss des dreitägigen Treffens mit
dem wir meinte die westlichen
Verbündeten die allerdings auch in
München keine Lösung fanden wie dieser
Krieg beendet werden kann russische
Vertreter waren nicht geladen deutlich
zeigte sich die Kluft zwischen den USA
und China ultra hat mehr
nicht auf öffentliche Bühne fand das
wohl wichtigste Treffen der
Sicherheitskonferenz statt
US-Außenminister Blinken auf dem Weg zu
Gesprächen mit dem chinesischen Chef
Diplomaten vangi mit einer Warnung fast
blinken nachher das Gespräch zusammen
wir machen uns große Sorgen dass China
darüber nachdenkt Waffen an Russland zu
liefern das hätte ernsthafte
Konsequenzen für unsere Beziehungen
es sind eisige Zeiten zwischen den
Weltmächten eine Lösung des Ukraine
Krieges ist wohl nicht zu erwarten
deshalb hat der Westen eine klare
Botschaft wir müssen zusammenstehen und
Europa muss stärker werden zum Beispiel
gemeinsame Waffen beschaffen
Frankreich Deutschland Polen und andere
haben verstanden dass Europa aufrüsten
muss
zum Schluss wünscht sich der Chef der
Sicherheitskonferenz Heusgen dass er den
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski
nächstes Jahr in Person begrüßen kann
der blieb aus Sicherheitsgründen diesmal
Weg
wir alle hoffen dass selenski hierher
kommt denn das würde bedeuten der Krieg
ist vorbei
es gibt drei Erkenntnisse von der
Sicherheitskonferenz erstens die
Europäer haben sich immer wieder
versichert an der Seite der Ukraine zu
stehen zweitens die Weltmächte finden
keinen Ausweg aus der Konfrontation und
drittens folgt daraus der Ukraine Krieg
wird wohl noch lange dauern
aus München ist US-Außenminister blinken
direkt in die Erdbebenregion der Türkei
weitergereist und sagte dort weitere
Hilfen zu auch die Bundesregierung will
ihre Unterstützung für Syrien um 22
Millionen Euro aufstocken sowohl dort
als auch in der Türkei sind
hunderttausende obdachlos geworden wie
eine Familie in der türkischen
Hafenstadt ich kenn darin damit umgeht
zeigt Peter Tyson
es ist ein Leben zwischen den Gleisen
das Hatice und ihre Cousinen dafür
führen das Haus in dem sie vom Beben
überrascht wurden ist vollständig
zerstört
Fenster und Scheiben im Wohnzimmer
zerbarsten die Leute schrien raus und
wir rannten voller Angst die Treppe
runter draußen regnet es heftig es war
apokalyptisch
zwei Tage schliefen sie im Auto nun ist
der Bahnhof von iskenderen ihr zu Hause
in einem abgestellten Waggon haben auch
die Großmutter und andere Verwandte
Zuflucht gefunden das gerettete Hab und
Gut es sind nur ein paar Kleider und
Decken hat Platz in der Gepäckablage
doch keine Klage kommt über ihre Lippen
wir sind so dankbar eigentlich haben wir
hier alles was wir brauchen schon
hier haben wir Wasser und Strom und es
ist doch angenehm warm und einigermaßen
bequem im Zug
insgesamt 400 Menschen leben in den
abgestellten Waggons gestrandet mit
ungewisser Zukunft denn bis die 280.000
in der Türkei zerstörten Wohnungen
wieder aufgebaut sind wird noch lange
dauern und so wird das Schlange stehen
zur Essensausgabe nach 10 Tagen zur
Routine
das Essen ist lecker ich bin wirklich
glücklich
es sind Glücksmomente für die Familie
von Hatice die fast alles verloren hat
aber eben nicht ihr Leben
bei einem Raketenangriff der
israelischen Armee auf die syrische
Hauptstadt Damaskus sind mindestens fünf
Menschen getötet worden das berichtet
des syrische Verteidigungsministerium
offenbar schlug eine Rakete auch in ein
Wohnhaus ein seit Beginn des syrischen
Bürgerkriegs 2011 hat Israel hunderte
Luftangriffe gegen Syrien ausgeführt um
den Einfluss des Iran im Land
einzudämmen
pflegende Angehörige entlasten der
Sozialverband VdK fordert dafür einen
Rechtsanspruch auf einen
Tagespflegeplatz vergleichbar dem
Rechtsanspruch auf einen Kitaplatz das
sei auch ein Schritt gegen den
Fachkräftemangel sagte VdK-Präsidentin
Bentele der Bild am Sonntag über zwei
Millionen fliegende Angehörige
arbeiteten derzeit nicht oder in
Teilzeit dieses Potenzial liege gebracht
drei Jahre nach dem rassistischen
Anschlag von Hanau wurde heute
bundesweit an die Opfer erinnert in der
Hanauer Innenstadt kamen hunderte zu
einer Kundgebung zusammen zuvor hatten
sich verbliebene und Freunde der Opfer
auf dem Friedhof versammelt
bundesinnenministerin Faeser und
hessensministerpräsident reinlegten
Grenze nieder
2020 hatte ein 43-jähriger deutscher
neuen Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
getötet danach erschoss er seine Mutter
und sich selbst
der Schwarm ist nichts für schwache
Nerven im Weltbestseller von Frank
Schätzing wären sich unter anderem Wale
und Riesenkrabben gegen das ausplündern
der Natur das Buch erschien 2004 das ZDF
hat den Füller jetzt verfilmt acht
Folgen mit viel Special Effects und
internationalen Partnern heute Abend ist
Weltpremiere auf der Berlinale
der Schwarm kommt auf die Berlinale mit
internationalem Star Ensemble die
aufwendig produzierte ZDF-Serie erzählt
vom Kampf der Meeresbewohner gegen die
Menschheit die viel zu lange schon ihren
Lebensraum zerstört
jetzt schlägt die Natur zurück gesteuert
von einer intelligenten Spezies in den
Tiefen des Meeres ein Thriller der
wissenschaftliche Fakten mit
Science-Fiction verbindet
für mich ist das eher so ein
philosophisches
Intelligenz beschließt halt das wie oft
man nicht so intelligent sind wenn wir
unseren eigenen Planeten zerstört mich
ja total schlau gefühlt danach weil ich
dachte ich verstehe jetzt
Wissenschaftler das ist sehr die Serie
verbringt viel Zeit damit
wissenschaftliche Zusammenhänge zu
erklären die Wahl sind wieder da fast 20
Jahre nach dem Roman setzt die Serie
eigene Schwerpunkte im Vorfeld gab es
Kritik von Autor Frank Schätzing
Experten die die Macher der Serie
wissenschaftlich beraten haben halten
die Verfilmung für zeitgemäß und
realitätsnah gut mit den Meeren umgehen
und ich bin froh darum dass es mal nicht
nur ein Vortrag ist von Wissenschaftlern
mit Daten und Warnungen sondern das ist
einfach eine Action-Serie ist die aber
diese Message und dieses Bild eben
unsere Arbeit so transportiert und heute
abend feiert die Serie weltpremiere auf
der Berlinale
und Sie können den Schwarm natürlich
auch sehen ab Mittwoch in der ZDF
Mediathek ab 6 märz im Programm und Ski
Alpin gab es heute auch Katja letzter
WM-Tag und der endete mit Gold für
Norwegen durch Henry christopherson im
Slalom für die deutschen Männer gab es
heute nicht die erhoffte Medaille dafür
überraschte Sebastian Holzmann mit einem
starken fünften Platz
für den 29-Jährigen aus Oberstdorf ist
das Meer als ein Achtungserfolg im
zweiten Lauf macht der 13 Plätze gut am
Ende Rang 5 damit hatte niemand
gerechnet
dem Norweger Henry Christopher sind
gelingt etwas ähnlich besonderes von
Platz 16 im ersten Durchgang fährt er
auf eins so hat noch keiner einen
WM-Titel gewonnen zweiter wird AJ
Guinness aus Griechenland der Italiener
Alex venezer gewinnt Bronze wird 9
zur fußball-bundesligaunion Berlin
spielt gegen Schalke in der ersten
Sonntagspartie nur 0:0 und verpasst
damit den Sprung an die Tabellenspitze
und nochmal Wintersport die Skispringer
Karl Geiger und Andreas Wellinger haben
den letzten Weltcup vor der nordischen
Ski-WM gewonnen in Rassen auf Rumänien
siegten sie im sogenannten super
Teamwettbewerb vor den Duos aus
Slowenien und Österreich und zum ersten
Mal seit 1969 bleiben die deutschen
Biathlon Männer ohne eine WM-Medaille am
schlussstag der Weltmeisterschaften in
Oberhof gegen aber auch die deutschen
Frauen im Massenstart leer aus es gewann
die Schwedin Hanna überberg
Dauerregen in Oberhof am letzten Tag
dieser Weltmeisterschaften dennoch die
Stimmung prächtig beim Massenstart der
Frauen wird schnell klar die Sprint
Weltmeisterin Denise Hermann Wiki
erwischt einen Raben schwarzen Tag
insgesamt fünf Fehler Platz 24 die
Schwedin Hannah Übergänge zeigt beim
letzten Schießen ihre Klasse fünf
schnelle Treffer zum Abschluss dazu eine
bärenstarke Schlussrunde nach Gold im
Einzelnen nur noch der Titel im
Massenstart Silber für Ingrid
Landratsamt Norwegen und Bronze gewinnt
die Französin Julia
verdiente platzierer bei dem Wetter da
bleiben wir auch dabei
im Norden gibt es morgen viele Wolken im
Nordosten Regen dabei weht der Wind
stark an den Küsten stürmisch im Süden
ist es freundlich und trocken die
Temperatur erreicht 8 bis 16 Grad
eine Gellinek begrüßt sie um viertel vor
zehn im heute-journal die gesamte heute
Crew sagt danke und tschüss und wünscht
Ihnen einen guten Start in die neue
Woche hier übernimmt
Berlin direkt